peut pas qu'est ce que ces maps
je sais pas ce que c'est
est ce que tu vas acheter un masque
[Applaudissements]
samedi 10h
le carnaval je crois à nice
je me déguisais non
pourquoi on va parce que j'ai pas
tellement infimes
fiché qu'est ce que c'est mardi gras au
c'est à une fois quel genre de fait
tu veux te déguiser pourquoi oui à
l'époque de la télévision et des voyage
dans la lune les masques du mardi gras
n'est pas de plus les enfants
c'est le seul jour de l'année où l'on
peut à loisir multiplié les voyages
leclerc et les rencontres diplomatiques
le masque a fait de gros progrès en
matière plastique souple il permet aux
grands enfants que sont les adultes de
figurer pour quelques heures parmi les
vedettes de l'actualité pour 38 francs
vous pouvez ce soir en rentrant joue
avec votre femme au devine qui vient
dîner ce soir
les faits seraient moindres avec les
traditionnelles masque durant carton
mâché qui toutes à peu près 10 francs
mais avouez que la différence en vaut la
chandelle
je trouve que c'est une perle une fête
qui se perd de plus en plus en province
ce choc que c'est beaucoup plus pratique
in le mardi gras est une fête beaucoup
plus en plus répandu sur la côte je sais
que la passion il ya une grosse demande
qu'est-ce que sur le boulevard beaucoup
moins de monde
en revanche vous vendez des masques pour
les adultes beaucoup plus pour les
grandes personnes qui s'amusent
nettement plus il ya beaucoup de soirées
organisées de bal costumé de différentes
choses donc la vente de masques souple
par exemple est une grosse demande quels
sont les plus demandés des masques
d'actualité comme le président giscard
d'estaing
des fois des autres président défunt il
ya aussi des présidents nixon unis
d'amérique
et puis beaucoup de demandes pour par
exemple le chirac qui n'est pas sorti
mais qui ne devrait pas tarder ah bon le
chirac sortira quant à l'or il faut
compter au moins trois semaines un mois
et en matière très souple et le giscard
se vend mieux aussi très très bien c'est
ce qu'on vous demande le giscard souple
le giscard duras oui parce qu'il passe
partout avec ça on rentre à la porte
[Musique]